one of the less spoken about debates in
the Bitcoin world is whether the
transition from Fiat to crypto whether
it's going to be a peaceful one or it's
going to be more turbulent in the last
three or four months we're already
seeing sort of some civil unrest around
the world do I know for a fact whether
17.5 was the ultimate bottom or not I
believe that that 20 000 Peak that we
had in 2017 which was resistance is
going to be flipped into support all
right guys bang bang got Murad here with
me Murad is one of the only people I've
ever talked to on the podcast which uh
after I had a conversation with them I
ran I bought more Bitcoin going all the
way back to I think 2018 is when we had
our first conversations from Rod I'm
happy to uh to get you back uh maybe
what we could do is just kind of do an
update in terms of your views of the
macro environment in Bitcoin obviously
there's a whole bunch of stuff that have
transpired on kind of Legacy Financial
system how do you evaluate the current
environment and the situation that we
find ourselves in now about two and a
half years after the pandemic started
so I would say that my bullishness
didn't really change whatsoever uh I'm
still as bullish as I was in November
2018 or October 2018 I believe it was
when we kind of recorded our last
podcast
um the long-term thesis didn't change at
all if anything the kind of room and
bust yet another woman boss that we've
experienced since has only strengthened
my result
um I still think it's a matter of time
before Bitcoin takes over I still think
it's a matter of time before
um sort of we
end up with
a slow hyperinflationary scenario
um I think we've seen sort of inflations
historically locally
but we are at a point in the world's
history where things are more
interconnected and inter-dependent than
ever
and so because of that we've never seen
a global hyperinflation right and what
I'm worried about is sort of a situation
could be three years from now could be
30 years from now but I definitely think
it's going to happen in our lifetime
um and um it's hard to say whether the
transition is going to be peaceful or
sort of more violent but we have to sort
of be prepared for both both situations
now of course we're in the middle of the
first quantitative tightening in
Bitcoins sort of 12 13-year uh history
now there was a brief period some a
brief similar of slight quantitative
tightening in 2018 but nothing that
we're seeing right now and generally I
would say
um yes of course Bitcoin isn't so much a
direct inflation hedge as it is a proxy
for monetary expansion and sort of a
monetary basis like N2 and three but uh
regardless of all of that I'm still
super bullish I think we are
in a beginning of a slow bottoming
process right now and it doesn't matter
whether we're going for a visit 17s
again or not
um I still think we've sort of begun
this wide rectangular multi-month period
of bottoming uh across the entire space
and I think uh today next month two
months from now these are generally
great times to sort of BCA back into the
market tell me more about the global
hyperinflationary type event what would
that look like or what would you be
looking for to say yes it's happening
now
well first of all I think we're kind of
in the early Innings of it and of course
it's not going to be an overnight thing
uh it's more likely to kind of also come
sort of in these waves of increasing and
reducing inflation but we're already
seeing inflation at like 42-year highs
and personally kind of the official
government statistics that we're seeing
in the world I think those are further
sort of artificially lowered I think
just by looking at the food prices and
the real estate prices that I myself am
experiencing I would say
things are kind of slowly getting out of
control now people think that it's
because of supply side reasons uh I
still think that the majority driver of
that is sort of the insanely aggressive
monetary expansion that we've seen sort
of spring 2020 onward
um but essentially there's a kind of a
one of the less spoken about debates in
the Bitcoin world is whether the
transition from Fiat to crypto whether
it's going to be a peaceful one and
there's definitely a path for that as
well
or it's going to be more turbulent now
in the last three or four months we're
already seeing sort of some civil unrest
around the world uh Albania Sri Lanka
Tunisia cost of Serbia Etc and in my
opinion uh sort of
if you look at history
Rising sort of bread and energy prices
have always been the biggest and the
most frequent sort of causer of
um any kind of upheaval or unrest right
so uh definitely just something to
consider definitely something to think
about uh as we sort of move forward in
in this age of Rapid change I would say
talk to me about the central banks
around the world and their role uh
through Market intervention in creating
some of these scenarios versus uh is it
external shocks and external event
developments that they're simply trying
to respond to uh and you can't really
lay uh fault or blame uh with the
central banks for either the 40-year
high of inflation that many countries
are seeing uh or things like a potential
recession uh which I would argue is a
recession in the United States
so I believe that a fractional
reserve-based banking system cannot
survive without intermittent
interventions of central banks into the
economy as I'm sure many other guests on
your podcasts have alluded to all in the
past this creates all kinds of
distortions when it comes to uh sort of
the the correct pricing of goods more
importantly and something that's less
talked about is I believe that
the government intervention in the
currency markets it makes inflation a
lot higher than it has to be which in
turn I believe is kind of the primary
cause of
mental health issues stress anxiety
because essentially it forces you at the
margin to prioritize short-term projects
over long-term projects and because of
that people essentially not just
financially but also psychologically are
essentially like living week to week if
not day to day and that creates a lot of
discomfort in people's minds right and I
think that this is like one of the one
of the 12 13 things that is is less
discussed and something that hopefully
will change for the better once we kind
of move to a Sounder system in the
coming years you've mentioned a couple
of times that that transition could be
peaceful or it could be a little bit
more turbulent what is your kind of
description of both of those scenarios
what is the peaceful transition look
like is it just people start buying
something like Bitcoin and over time the
percentage increases and and then
everyone starts using that and then also
what is the turbulent time look like in
your opinion given the facts and
information that we have today
so I guess I I kind of described a
similar metaphor a few years back but
effectively both Fiat and Bitcoin are
just two balloons right and with every
boom and bust cycle that we have in uh
Bitcoin effectively the peak of each of
the bull cycles is essentially an
attention wave right and with each of
those attention waves usually the
majority of the majority of the
participants the majority of new
participants of each generation in
Bitcoin Cycles predominantly comes at
the top and it is designed to be that
way right because with the top comes the
greatest amount of hype news marketing
attention right and
each of these sort of hard beats so to
speak
um
brings more people from the Fiat from
the Fiat balloon into the Bitcoin
balloon and
um
the peaceful scenario is one where that
transition happens sort of gently slowly
gradually and instead of a large number
of people in the world being caught off
guard
um by sort of the entirety of the
current monetary Paradigm sort of
blowing apart you have a relatively
sizable chunk of them already in the
Bitcoin system or in the cryptocurrency
system and the infrastructure to move
from one to another is already sort of
very well established and sort of that
movement of air so to speak from one
balloon to another it happens gradually
steadily peacefully and Fiat instead of
um exploding so to speak it slowly uh
sort of Fades into irrelevance instead
right
I don't know how realistic that is of
course that is the preferable way but I
think a darker pill so to speak is that
the exist the very existence of Bitcoin
is probably going to end up accelerating
a more rapid and sort of explosive
collapse of the current monetary system
in my opinion right now we don't know
when that's going to happen but like I
said I think it's going to happen in the
next several decades uh but personally I
lean towards sort of a more turbulent
scenario
and as that plays out what is the role
of Bitcoin in relationship to nation
states or central banks is it something
where the more turbulent it becomes the
more likely they are to kind of
capitulate and purchase it is it
something that they will avoid uh
because there's a confidence game and
kind of fractional Reserve Banking and
Fiat currencies how do you see those
relationships playing out today's
episode is brought to you by ftxus
they're a safe regulated way to buy
Bitcoin and cryptocurrencies they've got
very cheap fees sometimes as much as 85
percent cheaper than their competitors
there's also no minimum fees there's no
withdrawal fees or any other hidden fees
ultimately FTX us is trying to make it
dead simple for you to buy Bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies they also now have
digital stock trading as well with no
transaction fees and no payment for
order flow all you have to do is go
download the FTX app today from the App
Store and use code pop and you'll get
some money back every single time you
trade 10 or more again Go download the
FTX app today use code pop and every
time you trade 10 or more they'll go
ahead and they'll give you some crypto
back the more you trade the more you
earn download the FTX app today
so we need to understand that
governments at the end of the day are
composed of individuals right let's say
poor simplicity's sake a government is 5
000 people
we need to remember that what's best for
the government is
not necessarily what's best for each of
those individual people so the ideal
scenario is one where
a lot of the people around the world
including some of the government
officials and government institutions
start sort of capitulating from Fiat
into accumulating uh Bitcoin themselves
and then it sort of collapses from the
inside where the interests of the
participants start to starkly diverge
from the interests of the group as a
whole right
but um like I said
um both Fiat and Bitcoin are effectively
competing money products and let's if we
just ignore governments for a second as
an individual you're seeing one sort of
hyperinflate away while the other is
steadily across sort of medium long time
frames is appreciating in value and
effectively it's just a matter of time
before people put both on the shelf and
kind of realize that b is better than a
right and um I think it will only
accelerate the process of sort of
governments capitulating into it as well
um funnily enough
since 2017-18 people said that first it
will be like Savvy technological retail
then it will be sort of sad ABC's then
it will be sort of more established
institutions and then finally it will be
Sovereign wealth month but
um it's possible now I don't have I
don't know of any confirmed rumors of
course there is sort of uh some things
that we are hearing here and there uh
but we can't know for sure until
official announcements I wouldn't be
surprised if there are a number of
sovereign wealth funds that are sort of
slowly accumulating already and it makes
all the sort of mathematical sense in
the world to allocate one percent or
even less than one percent
um to to kind of this uh asset class
already but yeah I think I I think the
governments will capitulate into it in
in due time talk to me about mining
obviously there's a number of nation
states that are rumored uh to be
participating in various forms some you
know kind of prototyping and testing
others uh openly doing it like a country
like El Salvador
um how do you see Mining and
nation-state participation uh kind of
the level of importance there
I think China made a very big mistake
um by effectively letting uh a really
big chunk of the market move to the
United States Europe and other places
um we've really seen a sort of a
we're seeing sort of a slight
Renaissance in American Miners And I
think
um
it's probably better for Bitcoin for the
mining infrastructure to be uh
predominantly existing in a nation with
more established sort of property rights
and freedoms now of course
um there's still mining going on in
China right but the sort of the the
official the waves of official bands
that we've seen from the uh from the
Chinese central government and even the
Chinese entrepreneurs themselves
frequently posting pictures from like
Iceland Finland Sweden and the United
States itself these days on social media
um I think 10 years from now China will
realize that they've made a strategic
mistake in this regard
when we talked back in 2018 bitcoin's
price was somewhere between I don't know
three thousand five thousand dollars uh
it ran all the way up to sixty nine
thousand dollars in the uh a couple of
years since then we're now sitting
somewhere in the twenty thousand dollar
range uh the price action for a Trader
obviously would be super interesting but
one of the pieces of our conversation
back in 2018 was the demonetization of
other stores of value and you laid out
an argument and a framework to see
Bitcoin continue to rise in value and
measure by market cap uh could reach you
know hundreds of trillions of dollars or
over a hundred trillion dollars in value
as it demonetized these other store of
value uh that would lead to a bitcoin
price measured in millions of dollars
per individual Bitcoin and I think a lot
of people kind of said wow that's a
pretty uh interesting thesis it's a
pretty bullish thesis and and they were
drawn to it what is your kind of
analysis of the progress along that
thesis from 2018 to today so about four
years you know three and a half years
after
you kind of originally laid that out do
you feel like we're still moving along
uh kind of that same thesis and and uh
generally believe the same thing
I would say like if the odds of it
happening in my head were like 30 back
then they are like 50 now so I would say
it's even higher now
um every time Bitcoin grows in market
cap market cap is effectively
symbolizing the amount of attention the
amount of eyeballs that are looking at
this thing and so uh the fact that we've
went from 5000 to 69 000 back to twenty
thousand right now uh in the last three
years has only strengthened the bullet
points that I was bringing up three
years ago and the fact that there are so
many more participants now uh the
infrastructure is even more mature the
amount of Institutions is is even bigger
uh the amount of sort of famous famous
celebrities and financiers and other uh
sort of individuals that are
participating and supporting the
ecosystem is even greater now
um essentially the chances of everything
I was talking about in 2018 have only
increased since then simple as that in
my opinion all the bullet points still
stand and the eventual market cap
measured in today's dollars being over
100 trillion is completely realistic
and when you see that 100 trillion
number it's a big number what is the
expectation timeline wise you said the
probability of it happening has
increased do you still keep kind of a
multi-decade uh view from a timing
standpoint or has that been pulled
forward at all uh given what we've seen
transpire over the last three years
I think to to manage the expectations I
think somewhere between 10 to 20 years
is is a realistic possibility
could take a little bit longer could
even happen faster but something to the
tune of 15 to 20 years I think is
definitely possible we need to realize
that this is like a long-term game and
uh 400 year old currency paradigms don't
collapse overnight so of course it's
going to take time but
the fact that there's internet right now
and the fact that these like these very
Technologies are decentralized is going
to make it faster than it would have
otherwise happened
and when you look over the last three
years are there any negative surprises
in your opinion uh kind of the
development of Bitcoin or the adoption
of Bitcoin is there anything that's
happened that you're like you know I
didn't expect that to happen or maybe it
is a negative view of the progress today
yeah
so Bitcoin likes when Central Bank
prints money and it doesn't like when
they contract the money supply
um
now this the following is going to sound
a little bit simplistic but it does seem
that Bitcoin is even more sensitive to
contractions than what than how
sensitive it is to expansions now of
course there's other variables at play
like the stock markets sort of
collapsing as well and the the tech like
the tech industry also kind of
experiencing some downturns uh but
that's kind of one thing to think about
the other thing to think about is
um
the second thing I mentioned as well is
Bitcoin has become highly correlated
with other sort of risk Assets in
people's portfolios
But ultimately I think it was a bit of
an inevitability as Bitcoin kind of
matured into a trillion dollar asset
right now I think we are still in this
Middle Ground where we are going to
mimic uh sort of
a leveraged Technology stock still uh
for the next several years
But ultimately I still think that
Bitcoin is first and foremost correlated
with kind of the global Central Bank
monetary Aggregates and to to be most
specific so if that continues to expand
which over the medium to long term I
believe it will
um bitcoin price will continue going
higher uh in my opinion nevertheless
the last thing I want to talk about
Bitcoin before we talk about what you're
working on now uh is leverage and
obviously uh when there's leverage in a
system uh you usually can't see the
leverage if you're a market Observer or
it's very difficult to identify in the
Bitcoin and kind of broader crypto
ecosystem uh many times it is actually
uh much easier to see that leverage uh
and then when you couple that with wild
price wings both to the upside and
downside one it acts as an incentive for
people to take on more and more leverage
but also to uh there's kind of
punishment on the other side uh back in
2020 obviously you shut down a fund
um and then you've kind of watched over
the last three years as you've continued
to invest in the ecosystem and in the
industry what's your thought process
around leverage today how have past
experiences kind of change your opinion
about leverage and then what do you
really look at in terms of Leverage over
the last couple of weeks or months in
the Bitcoin ecosystem as we've seen a
number of existing businesses kind of
get Force liquidated due to leverage
that they had
yeah so if you have leverage
your uh sort of your outcomes path
dependent and if you're only holding
spot your outcome is not path dependent
really
um especially in the medium to long term
so I've experienced the dangers of
excessive leverage firsthand as many of
you may know uh but I I think despite
any kind of failures or or challenges
that you may face in life you simply
have to kind of stand up and try again
and again and again
um until until you succeed
um I would say that actually leverage
has become a little bit more opaque in
uh
2020 to 2021 and the reason I say that
is because
at least in the 2018-2019 era
the majority of Leverage existed on
centralized exchanges which still shared
a lot of the sort of open interest and
average leverage and sort of the long
short ratios and different kinds of
analytics with the end consumers so yes
of course every transaction is not
transparent on a centralized exchange
but they did share the aggregate values
with the market and kind of a lot of
quantitative analysts could extrapolate
that data with the amount of Leverage in
the system uh so some useful ratios
where the key liquidation points are Etc
unfortunately I think with some of the
sort of the Celsius uh Voyager three
hours Capital other stuff we've seen in
sort of 2020 uh 21 22.
um a lot of that stuff was a lot more
opaque because even though a lot of
these entities describe themselves as C5
um
the public or the average Market
participant wasn't privy to their books
uh their loans sort of the
aggressiveness of of of the of the debts
involved uh their average sort of
Leverage ratios there and so it's
probably for the better that that got
got sort of washed out of the system
every sort of bottom every every
approximate bottom of uh of a global
bear Market always has entities
capitulating and I've experienced
something like that firsthand But
ultimately it just leads
um it's kind of the pain going away and
opens up the door to a new market
participants kind of scooping up the
coins at cheap prices so
um it's just like like I said the the
inevitable symptoms of of the bottoming
cycle a recently was listening to an
interview and Jerry Seinfeld of all
people was talking to Tim Ferriss and in
it he said that pain is information or
education rushing in and he used the
example of when you stub your toe uh it
is the world telling you hey there's a
bed post there that you didn't think was
there and it's kind of a feedback loop
uh when I hear you talk about pain uh
when it comes to trading and leverage uh
same thing right kind of information and
education rushing in
um and and obviously nobody wants to
experience that but I think it's kind of
a fair way to look at
um you know some of that pain and and
what some of the optimistic uh takeaways
of it could be is that fair
yes uh these things are very very
expensive lessons yeah when you think
about uh kind of the market today uh you
now are building uh something that uses
some of the same Technologies but but is
quite different as well talk to me a
little bit about uh kind of your journey
from uh what most people would know in
terms of the most hardcore most
optimistic Bitcoin bull maybe they've
ever heard speaking to a microphone uh
to uh now somebody who is incredibly
bullish about Bitcoin but also has
become excited about other parts of the
industry as well what is that Journey
been like and maybe talk a little bit in
terms of how you get to the idea you're
working on now
yeah so obviously we've had a very big
defy summer in the summer of 2020. uh I
myself have gotten sort of more
interested in that Subspace of the
industry towards the end of 2020 more so
early 2021
uh one of the things I disagree with
sort of the your more vanilla Bitcoin
Maximus is that absolutely everything
else in the space is a scam other than
Bitcoin because I think that even if
Bitcoin becomes the dominant sort of
value in the dominant currency there's
still going to be other on-chain
businesses now whether you like it or
not or whether that diverts attention
from people only buying and only
studying Bitcoin doesn't matter the own
chain businesses will still exist the
idea that there won't be Revenue
producing and revenue sharing and cash
flow positive uh blockchain businesses
whether those exist on bitcoin or in any
other chain is completely Preposterous
and I think that actually the next cycle
will be defined by sort of decentralized
applications that make consistent money
and share that money with sort of their
community and I'm actually very excited
like if if we ignore sort of the store
of value discussions and and currencies
crochet I'm very excited by any kind of
D5 application that can enable that can
maintain they can create and maintain a
mode and that have sort of consistent
consistent fee generation I think those
are very powerful and very exciting the
fact that you can sort of build a
business that's completely untethered to
physical objects essentially and even
compared to the syntax of the 2010s you
don't really even need a bank account to
run any of this stuff uh you really just
need a bunch of computers and a bunch of
discords then that's it and so I think
that's unbelievably exciting I'm
building something similar in the space
as well uh our project is called stfx
essentially it's a
it's a completely new way to do
short-term Asset Management so since
2016 there have been many
um Asset Management products in the
ethereum and other ecosystems however
um they collected tvl of all active
asset Asset Management products in the
space right now is 50 million which is
essentially nothing and
the reason for that I believe and I
don't want to go through the entire list
I wrote a medium article kind of
describing the 12 reasons why this is
the case but essentially
um
people don't want to wait for years uh
in in any kind of a D5 Volt or in any
kind of vehicle uh they want something
faster and something with a faster
feedback loop so
what is a traditional fund it's
something that usually lasts for two
three years or more something that thus
far at least in crypto meant you hold a
portfolio of Bitcoin and maybe 10 15
other altcoins and you kind of rotate
between them
um and something that's continuous right
something that's portfolio Style
essentially you can think of every fund
as a series of 70 or 200 trades right
instead of doing a fund on chain we're
doing something we call single trade
funds so think about it as if you would
sit down with the lawyers in the real
world structure fund go through a
fundraising process load up the funds
through your exchange execute just one
trade and as soon as that one trade is
done the investors receive their
proportional p l you sit down back with
the lawyers to kind of wind down the
fund uh and essentially we do that but
it all happens in minutes right and the
decentralized exchanges particularly
those that focus on derivatives have
finally matured to a point in middle of
2021 where what I'm describing has
finally become possible
um I think on-chain funds in the
classical sense of the world are boring
so we are doing kind of on-chain managed
trades instead and instead of people
waiting for two years uh they only we
have to wait a couple of days to a
couple of weeks to kind of see the
result of their investment we think
that's a lot more exciting so if
traditional funds are molecules we're
trying to build atoms right and if
traditional funds are kind of 20-minute
YouTube videos we're trying to kind of
build the tick tock of asset management
on top of that the other way to think
about it is kind of Deep by since 2021
has kind of been undergoing a
vultification of everything moment
um
this means that many different kinds of
on-chain strategies have been packaged
into volts and kind of uh made
investable we've seen that with leverage
deal farming with managed with liquidity
management we've seen that with most
famously with options but we're trying
to do something similar but with
directional trading and we're making it
completely permissionless so I'm super
super excited uh if you want to learn
more join our Discord uh discord.ggstfx
so when you think about these short-term
trades
um I've got a whole bunch of questions
uh and as many people know I invested
mainly because you said you were doing
something and I didn't I don't even
think I asked you necessarily what you
were doing as much as just if you're
doing something I'm in uh but when you
start to look at
the short-term trade
is there anything you can look at in a
legacy world that would be kind of a
proxy or a comparison or is this
something that's brand new that wouldn't
be possible uh without this technology
this episode is brought to you by Ledger
the best crypto Hardware wallet
everyone's heard the phrase not your
keys not your coins and that's more true
today than it's ever been ultimately a
value proposition of Bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies is self-custody where
you get to retain ownership over your
digital assets that is what Ledger
specializes in they've got multiple
pieces of hardware and they also have
the Ledger live mobile app which makes
it seamless to not only retain control
over your Bitcoin but it also allows you
to interface with exchanges lending
platforms and other types of software
products if you're interested in upping
your self-custody game go check out
Ledger today
shop.ledger.com again that's
shop.ledger.com go check them out and
start doing self-custody you'll thank me
later
yeah that's a great question I've said
many times on Twitter that uh the use
like the crypto use cases that I'm most
excited about are those that are
completely fresh new and unique and are
specifically arising for the first time
because of sort of the convergence of
these Technologies
I personally don't think there's
anything in traffic that can compare
some of the closest kind of parallels or
metaphors that I can make is you know
how angelist is a place to develop
vehicles to invest in startups
now angelist even had Vehicles developed
for people to come together and to uh
invest in just one startup right so
there have been funds that just focused
on investing in one startup you can
think of our platform as Angelus for
trade so instead of investing in
startups you're investing in a trade
idea and you're sort of essentially
giving someone access to funds uh in a
non-custodial manner so obviously they
can withdraw run away with it but they
can manage it right you're essentially
giving somebody access to a portion of
your funds for uh between two days and
two weeks and
um essentially during that relatively
short term time period they're going to
be executing on their proposed trading
idea the other way to think about it is
you can think of it as a Kickstarter for
trades right instead of Kickstarter for
Charities this is a Kickstarter portrait
and the other kind of the last but not
least parallel that I can draw is if
you've ever used trading view you've
ever been on the trading view ideas page
we're trying to build something like
trading view ideas but that's very
easily fundraisable and investable in
one click
when you start to see people doing this
what prevents me as an individual if
somebody pitches me on a single trade
kind of going around them and just doing
the trade myself is it the complexity is
it a cost thing is it an access thing
like what what kind of keeps me uh as we
see in private markets all the time
people say hey I want to invest in this
company oh that's a great idea and they
try to go around the kind of fund uh
manager what how do you think about that
yeah so
um every single
stf what we call them single trade funds
they're going to have a relatively brief
fundraising period where anybody in the
world essentially can invest into those
vehicles uh some of the charts the
Privacy the Theses the the direction the
asset that the manager uses to
incentivize people to invest in their
stfs
um they're some of them are going to be
binding things like the asset and the
direction but some of them are not going
to be binding right ultimately the stf
is going to be managed and executed
discretionarily by the manager in real
time via Market orders and not set an
advanced violin orders so even if they
said they're going to enter it let's say
40 uh ultimately the manager is going to
decide when to enter and you never know
when that's going to be the case uh
additionally on top of that we are going
to be letting managers hide one of the
parameters of the trade and as they
build a greater reputation and greater
capacities they'll be able to hide two
or even more of the parameters of the
trade additionally we're building on
layer twos so kind of the actual
execution is going to happen a lot
faster than it was to happen on layer
once
and as people do this
are there simple trades like just like
hey I think right now is a good time to
buy Bitcoin and I'm going to hold it for
you know three days uh and kind of just
go long only and it's more like a timing
thing or is there other complexities
that you think uh certain types of asset
managers or kind of those with trade
ideas will be attracted to uh to the
structure
so
um
just like you said I think timing is
probably the single biggest service that
the managers will technically be uh
giving to their clients so it's timing
of the entry timing of the exit and kind
of shepherding the trade in between so
things like trailing the stop losses and
kind of exiting earlier than originally
anticipated or even not deploying to the
trade ID at all or deploying earlier
than they planned or at a different
price that they plan Etc so yes it's not
just about ideation execution and
specifically timing are the biggest
services that are provided here
um we are starting off with perps uh
Perpetual Futures uh simply because it's
already the most well known most well
most well understood highest volume
highest liquidity product in crypto but
um we think that if that finds product
micro fit these single trade funds can
of course expand to spot
options
nfts even as well as more complex trades
like longing and shorting something at
the same time and different kinds of
sort of uh simultaneous spreads things
like that how do fees work what do you
think the fees that folks will charge
like why will the fund managers do this
how do they make money and then also
what does that technically is that just
an on-chain uh kind of streaming payment
type mechanism or is there some other
way that the fees are transferred uh
between different Market participants
So currently we're thinking that
managers will receive around 16 to 17 of
the profits of that they generate and
the platform that we're building is
going to be taking sort of three to four
percent of the performance fees and
that's simply the default values
um as the manager grows in their uh
reputation AKA capacity we are going to
be charging them progressively less fees
right so the bigger and more successful
you become uh the less of the
performance fees that you have to share
similarly on the investor side we're
going to be charging a modest
um Management Field as well and
similarly to the managers manager side
uh the more and the better that you
invest as the manager as an investor uh
your fees start to quickly reduce as
well so we we charge a small fee on both
sides but as you sort of level up
um on either of the classes the fees
that you have to pay uh started
got it what is the biggest risk that you
see right now uh with stfx and how do
you guys try to mitigate that risk
I think at this stage uh ensuring that
we have successful product Market fit is
the most important thing uh like I said
we have bit have been like we've been
following we've been trying to be
opinionated and trying to develop this
product in a lean manner
um we're starting off with perks because
I think uh by utilizing other dedexes we
can enable people to use uh mild
leverage on top of their stfs as well I
think just given the current demographic
of the space that makes it more exciting
and makes it more likely to find product
Market fit than purely spot focused uh
on-chain Asset Management products that
we've seen since 2016-2017
um and essentially it's making sure that
the ux or the user experience is as
smoothless is as smooth and kind of
flawless as possible uh so these are
like the top two things that I'm
currently uh most focused on yeah and
talk to me about the team what are some
of the backgrounds of folks who are
working on this how much of it is a
technical kind of innovation or body of
work versus maybe more Finance related
or Market related
so we currently have almost 20 people I
believe it's 18 or 19 right now half of
the team is
um
an Anon and how the team is doxed so I'm
clearly one of the docs people uh but
other than myself there I've essentially
been building this side by side with six
people since February and we've kind of
been growing the team steadily since
then currently we have uh five engineers
and over 10 people on the sort of the
business marketing design ux Community
side of things we have a couple of
uh folks that used to work at Snapchat
uh and X Yelp individual and sort of a
number of people that have worked in D5
on things like pancake Swap and sort of
other uh other popular D5 protocols got
it and as you begin to look at the
market you mentioned earlier that
decentralized applications will lead uh
or kind of be a big piece of the next
bull market here how do you see stfx
fitting into uh kind of the the next
bull market is it an expectation that
this will become one of the dominant
kind of applications it's something
where you're really just targeting a
specific use case
yeah so um our ultimate goal is to turn
single trade funds into this new
Financial vehicle Financial primitive or
a money Lego like they call it in D5 and
I think that uh it's very interesting
what we're trying to do uh because
essentially
we are on a mission to unbundle the fund
right we're trying to take the idea of a
fund and use blockchain Tech to turn it
into a much smaller shorter faster and
more compartmentalized focused discrete
uh vehicle right now
I think they often say about technology
that some of the kind of new
breakthroughs they come and they start
looking like silly toys or silly games
and I think that this has been the case
with a lot of like D5 thus far but
um I think if we start getting
consistent volumes and improve ourselves
this has all the chances in the world of
becoming sort of this new Mini asset
class or rather this new uh Financial
vehicle right you can think of it as an
unusual fund structure
my last question for you is around
regulation uh obviously one of the you
know big things that seems to be coming
out of a lot of the contagion that we've
watched play out uh in the last couple
of months uh in the crypto ecosystem is
more likely uh increases in disclosures
and more regulatory scrutiny how do you
view what you're building now uh kind of
in that regulatory backdrop what what is
the types of participants do they have
to be accredited non-accredited U.S
non-us what's kind of the the breakdown
there
yeah so um first of all
before anybody can connect their wallet
to the platform they need to acknowledge
sort of all of our terms and conditions
among many other contingencies are terms
and conditions are are kind of
disclosures disclaimers risks uh privacy
policies as well as the website itself
uh will make you kind of agree that you
are not from one of the Ascension
countries you're not from the United
States you're not from sort of Cuba Iran
um
I believe Venezuela a couple of other
countries Etc so
um obviously we cannot because this is a
completely decentralized world we cannot
account for every single user but we
have been learning from other successful
D5 protocols and D5 daos thus far and
kind of taking the lessons learned from
them uh trying to imitate them to the
point that is kind of reasonable and
appropriate
as you begin to look at kind of the
current state of the ecosystem you
mentioned uh some bottoming that you
think is either playing out or started
to play out at least
um give us kind of your view over the
end of the year so we're recording this
uh you know beginning of August of 2022
the next six months what uh what do you
think uh is kind of the view there
so I've personally publicly started to
get some exposure in the 17 000s
um did I go all in not not yet
um do I still have some Fiat on the
sidelines yes
um am I going to sort of slowly continue
getting into the market yes
um I think do I know for a fact whether
17.5 was the ultimate bottom or not no
um I think uh
most bottoms are these wide uh
rectangles that's just the way it is and
um I think that we have kind of like
gotten into that tube so to speak so my
view is that for the next half a year
we're going to be pretty much ranging uh
right words
um
I'm not 100 sure whether the stock
market has already bottomed I lean
towards more of a no than as uh but
regardless I think
super Loosely speaking I believe that
that 20 000 people that we had in 2017
which was resistance is going to be
flipped into support right even if we
quickly go to 17 or even 15 doesn't
matter I think this kind of General 20K
area is going to flip into support and
kind of this has begun happening right
now so I think the kind of buying
slightly above 20 or slightly below 20 I
think that's a great time to get in
because in the next four four to six
years I think we're still going to be
higher than today yeah that uh I think
that that is a uh a fairly safe view of
the world but we will see as uh as you
and I both know over the years uh best
way to be surprised is to think one
thing in this industry and uh and think
that there's no other possibility uh
where can we send uh folks to find you
on the internet or find out more about
stfx as you continue to build it
yeah so I'm on Twitter at must stop
Murad that's m-u-r-e-d and you can find
all the relevant links there
um DMS are open so happy to talk to
anybody who's interested about any topic
my friend that is a very appropriate
Twitter handle because no one can stop
you so keep going uh and uh it's great
to have you back and publicly kind of
talking about a lot of this stuff uh and
I know a lot of folks I've learned a lot
from you so uh so we're all excited to
kind of see what uh what you continue to
build with stfx and then also continue
to see your your thoughts around Bitcoin
as uh it appears to continue to do what
uh what it was designed to do
for sure
um thank you so much for having me uh
once again after all these years and
sort of excited to continue their
conversation flowing whenever whenever
you're interested